hey everyone dfolo here and in today's
video we are going over the next Arc in
gigayakotami's mental mind trip of a
story that is Jujutsu Kaizen this
perfect variation Arc is actually peak
gigay writing as it starts to kick
things off in terms of the killing game
and gives us way more of an
understanding with how things are going
to go down throughout Earth the amount
of new characters abilities and just
pure freaking hype is amazing let the
girls go so damn hard in this Arc it's
just too good now obviously enough of me
creaming over father gigay and his holy
scriptures obviously if you are new
around here I Want More Story type
explain content just like this then be
sure to hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with
pushing my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people anyway sit back and relax
as we dive straight back into Juju
Kaizen so a quick reminder to everyone
is that obviously this Arc literally
picks up with things finished right at
the end of the last one with Yuji Yuta
migami and all of them in a conversation
over the Cullen game and the
implications around it with migumi's
sister having been revealed to be caught
up in the Cullen game for shikoro like
the best friend he is tells Yuji to let
go of his past mistakes the things he
can't control to instead help save his
sister now thinking of it as
grandfather's final words Yuji comes up
with a compromise he instead asks Yuta
to kill him in the event that sakuna
should ever take over his body again
YouTube believes that the big man akotsu
is stocky enough to be able to take him
down to which the second year agrees
saying that he'll do what he can so
after the agreement migami lays out the
plan to them they first need to contact
tingen and find out how to actually
unseal Gojo and what Brian kun's
objectives truly are the game itself is
a form of Jujutsu terrorism on a scale
that has never been seen before and
migami believes that they need answers
to ever mention questions Yuji asks if
Yuki would know to watch migumi reveals
that this was her idea and obviously
this goes to prove that instead of the
higher-ups like I said in the previous
video it was actually Mega me that she
was you know in contact with a tune that
Yuki is hiding at jiju high currently
and waiting for them while try to avoid
the higher-ups there Yuda goes on to say
that there is a problem with contacting
tingen due to the recent events back in
the Gojo past Arc tingen's concealing
barrier is active and shuffles over 1
000 doors continuously with only one
leading to him Yuji interrupts and asks
what the situation with nobara is but
only gets an encouraging saddened look
as a response from his boy trying to
contain his emotions Yuji leans over and
also looks to the ground while repeating
I get hurt
chosu who I somehow forgot to mention
was still around because he's my boy it
probably makes it known that he may know
a way past Yuji asks what he means and
chosen reminds them on how mahiso had
stolen some of sukuna's fingers in death
paintings from Jujutsu and the past then
goes on to say that he thinks he can do
the same thing skipping forward all four
of the boys which by the way like what a
freaking go to the group right here they
all into this school in secrets and mix
with Yuki and Mahi inside seeing Maki
for the first time since Shibuya it's
obvious that she's visibly taken a
freaking baiting from a fight with jogo
and Dagon there even after shoku's
reverse curse technique her body is
still severely mutilated concerned for
her Yoda goes up to Marquee and asks if
it's okay for her to be moving seeing
this though Yuki explains to him that a
reverse curse technique can't actually
prevent scars from Burns Mikey was
literally only able to survive jogo's
Flames because of the physical
durability granted to her through her
Heavenly restriction Maki then asks
Mecca me about their plan to slip past
the concealing barrier choso like the
big Pro years volunteers to inform the
group and explains that between the
correct door and the tomb is a cursed
Warehouse where his brothers are
currently being stored his connection to
them will allow him to guide everyone to
the correct door Maki is satisfied with
the plan but she needs clarification on
who exactly choso is after a brief
silence Yoshi reluctantly tells everyone
just to think of choso as his big
brother for now which like oh my Lord
choso must have had like fireworks go
off inside of his head or something like
even in reality he's visibly shocked and
excited to finally hear that Yuji is
saying his name skipping forward chosu
guides the group to the correct door
confident that his brothers sleep Beyond
it Yuji is surprised to find that there
is no solar path Beyond the Doors just a
massive drop into a forested area filled
with tall old trees after Yuki tells
them to move forward and searches the
elevator the group walks past a
warehouse which also stops for a moment
he reluctantly touches the door and asks
his brothers to just wait a little
longer for him to return and save them
honestly I want to make shoso who's one
of either choso's brothers or sisters I
feel like it's going to be a goated
female version of choso like honestly we
just we gotta have her in the series as
well if chosa was this cool after the
group takes the elevator down to the
Tomb of the star Yuki notices blood
stains on the ground and asks what
happened Yuki says that it's the remains
of when everything in the Jiu Jitsu
World began to distort even picturing
the demon himself for shiguro in her
mind after a moment Yuki moves on and
leads them directly to the main Shrine
and once there they walk into nothing
but a completely stark white void with
everyone confused Yuki says tingen is
currently rejecting them normally The
Entity doesn't interact with the world
but Yuki thought contact may have been
possible now that Gojo has been sealed
she also considers the possibility that
tinken isn't rejecting everyone and
instead just tour this is you know
obviously just due to the fact that she
has her own agenda and in some ways
wouldn't mind knocking off all of the
higher-ups Just Like Gojo unsure of what
to do Yuda tells everyone that they
should head back since migami's sister
doesn't have time to waste suddenly a
voice rings out and asks why are they
all leaving so soon
the thumb of an entity then appears
Master tingen finally reveals himself
while saying it's a pleasure to meet the
children of the Xenon family machizane's
descendant which I I really hope I
didn't botch because it always sounds so
freaking weird in my head the death
painting womb and finally sukuna's
vessel while everyone else is surprised
by tingen's thumb-like shape Yuki asks
why tingen didn't address her in their
greet him Tegan replies that this isn't
the first time they've met Yuki's next
question is why the Tomb of the star was
closed to which it's revealed tingen is
unable to see into the human heart and
feared that Yuki was aligned with
kinjaku finally like oh my God I can
stop calling him by the 900 names I keep
giving him as it's explained through
tingen here that hinjaku is the real
name of the body switching entity that
was once known as narutoshi kamo and now
inhibits the body of suguru gito Yuji
like the absolute melon he'd hears Cuts
in on the conversation to ask why tingen
look so freaking weird while mikumi
stands there surprised with Yuji tenkin
explains that even though his curse
technique grants a form of immortality
it's not anti-aging 11 years ago when
the star plays my vessel failed tingen's
aging process accelerated and the
self-awareness it had as an individual
diminished therefore it was forced to
evolve and now technically has become
one with the world itself which is a lot
to take in and has so many implications
in this story they have like even yet to
be explained like what even is this
Evolution he was meant to go through
like why was it considered bad in the
Gojo past Arc if it didn't assimilate
when now he can still control the
barriers and all of that kind of stuff
anyways anyways mikimi and yuto get to
the point and ask about kinjaku's
objectives along with unsealing Gojo
from the prison realm tingen goes on to
say that he will provide information on
one condition at least two of the three
people prison did a special grade must
remain at the Tomb of the star to serve
as guards since the lot are kind of
confused as to why tinken explains that
King jaku wants to force the evolution
of all of the people in Japan but he
can't do this while tenkins barriers are
active because that requires an insane
amount of cursed energy starting an
evolution of that scale using the cursed
technique is utterly inefficient instead
the Mythic kinjaku has chosen as to
merge tengen with mankind itself since
evolving into this new state it is now
possible for tingen to merge with
someone who isn't the star place for
vessel any human who merges with the
tingen evolves into something Beyond a
sorcerer that is both there and not part
of the Physical Realm at the same time
tinken stabilized and maintains
self-control even after evolving thanks
to the barrier techniques but says the
world would end if anyone merges with
him it's explained that there would be
no boundaries between individuals and
the impurities of millions of humans
would flood the entire world what
happened to Tokyo would engulf the
entire planet resulting in any world of
cursed Spirits what's actually insane is
that tingen also can't refuse the merger
because the failed assimilation has
caused them to turn into more of a curse
Spirit than a human being which is
obviously a perfect Target for someone
with curse manipulation so kinjaku's
plan is finally revealed Honestly though
like the amount of time it must have
gone into this plan and sitting upper in
preparation and getting all the people
that he needs to get it must have been
absolutely freaking mental anyways due
to the threat of kinjaku coming to
unseal the tomb the corridor is
rejecting everyone that approaches hence
you know like the white room King Jacob
was the one who set the plan in motion
they'd stop the merger 11 years ago it
was also involved with sukuna over a
thousand years ago to which Yuki wonders
why is he making a move just now it said
that the tingen star plays my vessel and
six eyes are connected by Fate kinjaku
has been defeated by two different
success users in the past and after a
second defeat he managed to kill the
star plasma vessel and the next six size
user the day after they were born yet
despite all of these efforts they still
somehow appeared on the day of the
merger what tingen being left at a dead
end made him switch to the method of
sealing the six eyes instead of
attempting to eradicate it completely
however an eternal fate that neither
tingen or kinjaku ever expected 11 years
ago the Heavenly gifted demon toji
fushiguro intervened a man who escaped
curse energy entirely and therefore was
not bound by the chains of Fate that
affected the Jujutsu World an effect
told you destroyed the Destinies that
bound tingen the star plasma vessel and
the six eyes then along with toji came
Suga dugito a boy who just happened to
be able to manipulate cursed Spirits
then after what could have been a
thousand years worth of research hinjaku
secured the prison realm six years ago
and all his plans fell into place so in
all actuality this game is a ritual to
really the people of Japan for a massive
merger with tingen it uses the player's
curse energy and the barriers to
transfer everyone to the other side
through the these weird veil-like
Customs Tinker can be forced to merge
with all of humanity in order to pull
off something of this level kinjaku has
restricted himself with these binding
vowels one stipulates that he is not the
game master so even killing him will not
end the game instead the only way that
it can end is once all of the players
are dead and there are rules in place to
ensure that nothing can interrupt the
original ritual the other best possible
course of action for them would be to
expend 100 points to add rules when
migumi's sister and others who are
unwilling to participate can escape the
game free and Saturday Gojo would also
be extremely ideal but before tenkin
reveals how they're able to do this it
requires the group to pick two of them
to serve as guards they are like big
thumb drop in a truckload of freaking
insane information that changes the
entire landscape of the world like it
truly goes to show how much time and
effort has gone into this plan on
kinjaku's side even now if he dies his
plan is still in place and he expects
that he will come out top no matter what
following this Yuki and choso volunteer
themselves as choto knows Yuji will need
you this help and this will also give
him a chance to protect his brothers
shukinjaku comforting In Here yuhi Also
isn't finished talking with tingen
either way and would like to stay back
if that's meant with the others wanting
to be around everyone else you happily
agrees with the plan after thanking them
tingen then proceeds to take out the
back of the prison realm explaining that
it is a separate cursed object that will
be necessary and unsealing Gojo after
hinjaku found the front he had the bag
back in jaku now Bears complete
authority over their prison realm as the
bearer of the front gate and can block
them from accessing the bag breaking it
open is instead the only way and would
require curse tools they can cancel
cursed techniques like the inverted
Spirit of heaven or the black robe
however both of those were lost in
secret battles with Gojo so like
obviously for those who don't know what
these are it's the blade that toji used
in his fight with Gojo 11 years earlier
in the Gojo past Arc and the black rope
that Miguel used against Gojo during the
night parade of a hundred demons and
introduced to Kaizen zero but you know
anyways anyways in an attempt to look
for more of like that rope user had
already been searching in Africa with
Miguel but sadly to no avail as it takes
centuries for them to create something
like it however there is still one way
to get into the back of the prison realm
a thousand years ago there was a female
sorcerer who called herself Angel she
possessed a cursed technique that could
extinguish others curse techniques
pretty much nullifying them her name is
Hannah kurosu and she's been incarnated
as a culling game player honestly this
character poses so much of like a
curveball to the game why is kinjaku
decided to also revive or bring back
this sorcerer what's the specifications
around her coming back and being a part
of this game there has to be some like
reasoning behind it allowing someone who
would like pose a threat to the
Integrity of the game to come back and
participate in the first place seems
kind of wet you know tingen repeats that
Angel's technique will be necessary to
open the back of the prison realm with
everyone confused making me asks where
Angel is and tenkin can only say that
she is in the colony on the east side of
Tokyo it is then shown that there are 10
colonies that are connected by barriers
that form a line down Japan this line of
barriers will merge everyone in Japan
with a tingen and transfer them to the
other side Hokkaido isn't actually
included because it's already been
established as a sacred area there has
been assimilated which is like what do
you mean by that as Hokkaido reminiscent
of ancient Japan in regards to the curse
spirits and fights that are currently
going on there anyways anyways this
whole mental idea of evolving Humanity
by merging the watingen's current state
is extremely complex and sounds somewhat
exaggerated however this is only a
testament to how serious the situation
actually is thinking their reveals that
a curse head in sacred merged with every
single person in Japan in preparation
for the merger and believes it will now
only take about two months to fully
complete the ritual the group then goes
over the rules of the Cullen game once
again the first rule states their
players must declare their participation
at any colony of their choice within 19
days currently it's 9 A.M on the 9th of
November and all players have awakened
their curse techniques around midnight
on the 31st of October which was when
kinjaku initiated the Countrywide idle
Transfiguration this only gives migami's
sister 10 days and 15 hours to declare
participation in the culling game this
second rule states that anyone who
breaks the first rule will be subject to
curse technique removal Marky had
previously talked with shoko about this
rule of the game believing the acoustic
removal implies that it's not through
idle Transfiguration or a binding vowel
but instead she thinks that it must be
something that must happen to the user's
brain which would in turn kill them as
if it was a vow all players could simply
refuse participation tinken confirms
shoko's theory meaning that people like
Maki who currently don't even possess
cursed energy are actually at a risk of
dying rule number three explains that
anyone who enters a colony after the
games have begun will be considered an
official participant civilians and said
the barriers will be given one chance to
exit and there are currently no rules
about entering or exiting colonies when
the game starts players will be given an
incentive to move towards the colony
excerpts this serves as an incentive to
stimulate participation as in order to
confine players effectively they must
believe they entered the games of their
own free will the fourth rule was the
one that states players score points by
killing one another the fifth one
specifies that each player's points
value is determined by the game master
currently Sorcerers are worth five
points and non-sorcerers are worth one
having just heard of this game master
tingen explains to them that each player
receives a shikagami known as cocaine
this creature serves as the game's
interface while the game master serves
as the program that runs it in some way
obviously this concept is super
confusing as gike is on his Astro [__]
like even Yuji is lifting a comically
lost State rule 6 states that players
can spend 100 of their own scored points
to negotiate a new role in the game
these rules can't be subtracted but
migami thinks they might be able to
create other rules as roundabout ways to
counter the original ones without
disrupting the game in accordance with
rule 6 rule 7 states that the game
master must accept any new rule as long
as it doesn't have a long lasting effect
on the game the group wonders if the
rules of fear buttingen assures them
they can Joker receives no bias towards
himself with these rules and they can
expect to be treated fairly just like
any other player the eighth and final
rule states that a player will be
subject to curse technique removal if
this score does not change for 19 days
this causes you to worry about whether
or not he'll have to kill others but
again Mega me suggests that he might
have a few ways around that with all the
information thoroughly reviewed Marky
then begins to go over everyone's role
Yuki and choso will remain at the Tomb
of the star while will return to the
zening clan to collect the missing curse
tools now that Mega me is the zening
Clans leader Marky will be able to use
this to her advantage to get them Maki
then inquires about the location of
Joseph kamiya's Workshop what she will
go to before recruiting Panda to the
group this juuzo dude in his Workshop is
the guy that gakuganji fought and the
one that Gojo later absolutely mangled
like broke all those limbs they must
have interrogated him for the location
of his Workshop where he made all his
weird ass tools and stuff anyway you
will instantly take part in the Cullen
game to gather information long
performing sister and the others have to
join Yuji will try to avoid nearby
colonies to prevent collateral damage in
case something happens but because of
this he might be out of touch since the
barriers likely block phone reception he
quickly realizes this presents an issue
as Yuji asks Yuta to kill him should
sakona ever appear again they both think
for a moment until migami says that Yuda
can just kill Yuji if he dies first but
Yuji wants to try prevent migami's death
in the first place Maki tells yuchi and
migami that their role is to find Hikari
Kenji the suspended third year and to
recruit him to their group despite his
Moody attitude akari is apparently
insanely tough with you to go in as far
as to say that when he's riled up
hakaris passes everyone even him in
strength after this everyone finally
moves out but not before Yuji thanks
choso for everything he has done so far
and while he waves goodbye his big bro
tells him to not go dying on him out
there meanwhile at probably a similar
time in a random comedy club called the
public stand everyone sits around bored
with an act that's obviously bombing on
stage like the man visibly sucks ass at
comedy his name anyway turns out to be
fumuhiko takaba his mate tells the 35
year old takaba to quit because he's
simply not cut out for the job this
massive Japanese dude who just happens
to be in the corner says he doesn't mind
his dumb jokes he thinks there are two
types of of comedians who will always be
in demand Comics who are funny and
Comics who wholeheartedly believe that
they are funny kin who's the mess of
Japanese dude asks takaba which of the
two he believes he is takaba says it's
50 50 at first before receiving a
strange impulse then deciding to change
his answer to 70 30. well well hasn't an
Army's technique revived itself and
someone else I don't know just a thought
I love the idea that it could possibly
be The Reincarnation of nanami's
technique or at least I hope it is
anyway skipping back to a moment shortly
after Panda's Birth masamichi has seen
confined in his cell with both of his
hands bound it's explained through
gehukanji that it's normal for a curse
corpse to operate independently as they
usually consume cursed energy provided
by its user in comparison panda is a
self-supporting cursed corpse that can
generate his own cursed energy pretty
much like the man literally created life
itself because of of us the higher-ups
were in the process of designating him
as a special grade and actually imposing
him with an indefinite restraint after
stating this to him Goku ganji asked how
Panda was made but masamichi insisted
that he didn't know now in the present
Yaga is only run but chilling only
forest with one of his dolls the curse
corpse is able to talk and calls out to
masamichi saying everyone is worried
about how gloomy he's become masamichi
pets his head and reveals that he won't
be able to return anytime soon adding
that Master team can protects the forest
they are currently hiding in after
saying he'll be fine on his own they
head over to a tree where Yaga opens a
small door inside many of his small
harmless independent cursed corpses
reside knowing that they will never see
him again they tell him they will all
miss him meanwhile and so the isolation
holding chamber executes you high
kuzukabe uses his Katana to cut Panda
free he goes on to say that he is doing
this as a favor to repay masamichi but
make sure or to tell Panda to not reveal
who helped him flashing back to the past
once again we learn they must admit she
created an independent cursed corpse
with kusakabe's nephew's Soul
information kusakabe's sister had lost
his son and couldn't live on without the
support that he was providing her one
day when she was brought to Yaga a small
dog-like doll asked if that woman was
his mother then goes on to say he's a
genius after being confirmed right by
Yaga kuzakabe's sister immediately
recognizes her son's mannerisms and
instantly darts out of her catatonic
state to embrace him after the two
console each other masamichi explains
that he couldn't allow takuru which is
the real child's name like not the doll
but like the real child to live with his
mother as he couldn't risk a getting out
that a fully independent curse corpse
existed even still kusakave apologized
and emotionally expressed his gratitude
towards masamichi for doing so by the
way this whole moment it just happened
was actually before Panda was even born
I forgot to mention that but it probably
makes a bit more sense on how the fact
that no one knew an independent curse
corpse existed at the time back in the
present day Yaga is confronted by an
unknown sorcerer he asks where masamichi
is going without any of his cursed
corpses to back him up while removing
his jacket like the freaking absolute
Beast he is the principal simply replies
that he is going to see his son this
sorcerer is left slightly confused as he
doesn't know what masamichi means but
goes on to explain the severity of the
current situation the principal finds
himself in he says the only way to save
himself now is to reveal how to create
independent cursed corpses immediately
asimichi says that his adversaries have
gotten comfortable getting pushy without
Gojo around to which these sorcerer
agrees especially as he's been
accompanied by a veteran sorcerer On Cue
yakuganji suddenly steps out of his
shadows and Deals masamichi a fatal blow
to his chest shattering the electric
guitar and leaving him mortally wounded
with two deep cuts across his front
forming an x-shape that also split his
blood alongside the wall Jacob tells the
sorcerer accompanying him to leave the
two principles alone then with his last
words masamichi suddenly begins
explaining exactly how to create
independent cursed corpses he states
that his Soul's information can be
replicated from physical information and
imported into cursed Corpse's cause
these cores must contain three highly
compatible Souls which are always
observing each other this is the only
way Souls will stabilize and give rise
to self-awareness and self-sustaining
cursed energy confused and shocked by
all of us dakuganji asks why masamichi
will tell him now instead of trying to
live by revealing this earlier just then
before passing away must meet your
replies that it's a curse being passed
on from him tokokuganji instantly after
Panda arrives only moments too late just
as masamichi dies kakuganji throws down
the broken remains of his weapon in
anticipation for panda to retaliate
however Panda simply walked straight
past them towards masamichi without so
much as ever glancing Edgar ganji
confused he asks why panda doesn't fight
but Panda reveals that he's not like
humans and their behaviors do not blind
him he understands that kakuganji was on
good terms with masamichi and these
orders probably came from the higher ups
even so pandas sheds a tear for his
father and tells the koganji to remember
that even pandas cry which is just like
too damn sad man recent peace big
musumichi absolute go anyway anyway now
we skip away to the absolute brutality
that happens over at the Zenon household
I call my Lord you guys are not ready
for what is about to happen if you have
not seen this moment you are going to
literally freak it is so good our girl
oh let's get into it so in order to
fulfill her role in helping with the
culling game Marky returns to a place
where she's never felt welcome as she
enters these Indian household to collect
the curse tools she's immediately
greeted by the misogynistic neo-year
seeing how scarred she is now he taunts
her as he believes or Maki head was your
attractiveness and now that it's gone he
asks if he should mercilessly bully her
like he used to in the past he continues
to throw abuse towards our girl however
she just ignores his crude ass and heads
on underground after the scene in some
of the stairs into the underground
Corridor Maki finds her mother awaiting
her there she reminds her daughter that
they cannot enter the warehouse to which
Maki like the boss she has nonchalantly
holds up their keys while saying that
Mega me is the new hit of the clan and
gave her permission and he flashback we
find out that Marky was actually the
person who revealed to Mega me that he
had become the head of the clan heavily
reluctant with the idea of being head
making me suggest that he let Maki take
over for him instead but she denies the
option as she knows no one would accept
her she points out that he's inherited
visiting Clans prized tin Shadows
technique and achieved its domain
expansion Mega me really didn't want to
take the role as head and asked if
things like acceptance mattered if she
becomes a clan here she would still get
the race sources but Maki doesn't
believe she's good enough to make this
home a place where my belongs not yet
once Maki said that about her sister
migami finally understood in the present
as Marky cruises past her mother she
suddenly screamed at by her to stop and
instead come back maki's mother asks why
her daughter is always like this and
tells her to at least make her mother
proud once for giving birth to her
however Maki just completely ignores her
pleas and continues on until she finds a
door that seals the cursed Warehouse
after using the key to unseal the chains
holding their doors together Maggie
finally enters however she's instantly
shocked to see her father unexpectedly
sitting inside of the room without a
single curse tool in sight marky's
father who was another of the
misogynistic lot reveals that he
anticipated marky's move and emptied out
all of the curse tools beforehand he
stands up and reveals mice injured body
behind him Mai seen Mikey there for the
first time calls her it for coming which
is really random when you put it in that
context meanwhile junichi meets with
naoya to filament on these circumstances
jinichi explains anayo that Megami is
the better choice for the clan head
because of his good relationship was set
at a Gojo and narutoshi kamo at the same
time jinichi refuses to allow an
outsider to inherit the entire Fortune
naioya asks why they don't just get rid
of him but then you need she explains
that they can't do that killing migumi
outright will hurt these inning Clan
standings with the other Gojo and kamo
Clans and they would fall behind in the
power vacuum left behind by Saturday
asks why they're doing it now if that's
the case engineer she explains that
they're going to take advantage of the
notice from Jujutsu headquarters it's
explained there through them that it's
been deemed a crime to unseal Saturn
Gojo so this inning Clan is going to
execute migami Maki and Mai as Rebels
plotting to do so now he is amused by
the plan and while killing his own
daughters will boost ogi's credibility
know your wonders if he is actually okay
with the idea to which as the battle
begins between father and daughter
junichi reveals to naoya that this plan
was originally ogi's idea which just
goes to show like how [__] up this
inning Clan is and how old all of their
thoughts are like look at the house the
woman the men the clothes like literally
everything it's it's time to move
forward zinnon Clan you just you guys
just do not get it like don't get me
wrong I actually love it because that's
the whole point of the sect in a way to
make you hate the group while still
wanting to know more about all of them
especially naoya like that dude has just
reading absolutely perfectly back as the
battle starts off Okie activates his
falling Blossom emotion he explains that
he kept Mai alive as a bargaining chip
in case Marky arrived with any unknown
curse tools that cause in an emergency
situation Marky wields juuzou's
Masterpiece the goated curse tool dragon
bone its effect or ability I guess is
that after accumulating cursed energy
the user can inject it out the back of
the way to increase its cutting power
Mikey plans to take advantage of ogi's
ignorance and bait entering a single
strike Jewel while actually intending to
hit back multiple times just before
indemny's standoff Augie asks why Mikey
thinks neobito was chosen over him as
head of the clan Mahi asks if it's
because he's a terrible person willing
to kill his own children which instantly
prompts Okie to start the fight as Okie
darts forward she blocks his first slash
and follows up with an attack of her own
utilizing the momentum granted by cursed
energy shooting out the back of the
blade oh he tries to Parry but quickly
notices his katana blade is actually
broken allowing Marky to get behind him
and go for the finishing blow however
with some unrealistically fast tie me
from an old timer Okie quickly spins
around and counters for this blazing
curse technique momentarily solidifying
his blade before he cuts Maki down
Mikey's already busted eye as a game Hit
and cuts open along with her lower
abdomen which was sliced through from
the attack left definitely injuries Maki
doesn't understand what happened until
she realizes that Oogie's blade has been
replaced by the Flames of his cursed
energy as she falls defeated Okie shoots
a tear and reveals he couldn't become
head of the clan because his children
are indeed worthless
man I like I said I hate this in
family's ideology and like Jujutsu in
general like if you wanted your kids to
improve you would teach them techniques
and not treat them like absolute ass all
the time that's not Marky who's the
failure on this like situation Mr ogisan
it was your failure as a hero to teach
your children correctly and guide them
and now it is time to pay the
consequences as Ogie drags his twin
daughter's bleeding bodies down a
corridor leaving a trail of their blood
behind him he explains why Marquee lost
he says that she stepped in close and
treated her opponent like his swordsman
and not a sorcerer who repeats that he
did not become head of the clan because
of the quality of his children
naobito's projection sorcery technique
doesn't have much of a history outside
of passing it down to na oh yeah so this
was not a determining factor and a
choice the only difference between them
was how strong their children turned out
to be Oggy states that children must not
hold back their parents and tosses his
daughter down a flight of stairs like
the trash he thinks they are into an
empty large room he explains this area
is for training and discipline a
plethora of curse Spirits are kept fear
they will eat the twins as soon as Ogie
leaves he mocks Marky and claims her
Heavenly restriction is nothing compared
to other sorcerers who trained and
reinforced their muscles with curse
energy every single day for years on end
her father then turns his back on his
daughters and says farewell to the
stains of his life one final time before
the curses move in Mai is able to sit up
and puts marky's head on her lap as she
feels Mark is heart beating she knows
how tough her twin truly is okay I used
to hate Mai but like really in this
moment right here it fully changed my
total outlook on her I always thought
that she was just another of the Xenon
household content with the way things
are and that's why she was always a
[__] towards Marquee but right now we
find out that Mai suspected that this
would happen someday and is ready to do
what is necessary to save her sister she
opens marky's mouth and says this sucks
before breathing the life back into her
suddenly Marky awakens somewhere on a
beach as if she's been rescued from
drowning which is like so cute literally
like she breathed the ear back into her
after drowning in the crap from her
family like it's such a great analogy
right here from Giga she's laying next
to Mai who explains that she's going to
use a construction technique to make
something but will then die from this
strange due to the injury she's already
sustained Mike gets up in his sand and
walks into the water or saying goodbye
and washing her twin good luck in life
this greatly confuses Marquee who gets
up and begs her sister to come back Mai
explains that she knew for a while that
twins are a bad Omen for Sorcerers to
gain one must give however that rule
doesn't always apply to twins because
curse energy treats them as One Singular
entity even if Marky wants to get
stronger she can't because why doesn't
so it was sad and as messed up as it is
as long as Maya's around Marky can never
fully develop in an attempt to get her
sister to stop Maki tells her that she
understands but she still doesn't want
to lose her sister and runs after her
asking for her to come home again Mike
stems her hand to Marky telling her that
she is only going to leave her one thing
so make sure to throw the rest away my
will take away all of the acoustic
energy when she dies so in return she
asks Maki to promise her just one thing
destroy everything
Market takes a small read from her
sister's hand and reflects on the time
they were happy as children and the next
moment hell itself has returned as Marky
awakens in reality noticing that she's
holding a sword handle instead of a reed
and a moment of beauty she's being
protected by her sister who has
tragically topbled over her with no more
Life Lift a new body overwhelmed by
emotion Mahi cries out and tells Mai to
wake up while a bunch of curse Spirits
Rush up behind her skipping over to the
old man as he walks away he notices
something that just doesn't feel right
and turns around to see what's up
Suddenly all of the cursed Spirits are
exercised instantaneously confusing Okie
as their presences just vanish for him
okay like remember our girl is now
outputting zero NADA none literally no
curse energy at all in her staff it's
just them pure gains time to see what
really pays off physical strength
through training your entire life occur
strength ogi oh he readies his Katana
and says Marky strolling through the
Shadows of the doorway before she gently
places Mai's body down Oogie's body
begins to trample with fear as he knows
his mind has tried its best to forget
this feeling Mucky emerges from his
shadows and instantly reminds him of no
one other than a demon Warrior who
possessed no cursed energy the breaker
of Fate himself poji Xenon struck with a
jolt of fear Okie immediately activates
his curse technique blazing courage
causing his katana's Broken Blade and
scorching Flames that blaze a circle
around him with his scorching blade
pointed at Mahi Ogie threatens to burn
his worthless child to the bone in a
fight to the death however before he
could even finish talking Marty like the
freaking Beast she's always being
effortlessly decapitates his head while
walking past him in fact I don't even
know how much of a specific buff this
was like we have to get big old broken
Ronin on it or something but the slash
was so damn fast that okay he never even
saw it coming Maki stops behind her
father's defeated corpse as it falls to
the ground she looks at the last gift my
gave her then ready to keep her promise
gripsley cursed tall in her hand and
tells Mai it's time to get started time
to start the absolute destruction that
is about to happen like oh I can't wait
literally like as an alarm bell sounds
out notifying the zidden clan janichi
and naoya leave their mating room and go
into a hallway young Ranter zinan finds
them and tells jinichi that Maki has
gone mad and actually killed Okie which
leaves the others completely surprised
so since these inning Clan is like just
freaking massive they have a variety of
different groups consisting of people
with varying skill levels one of these
is the 50-man kukuru unit that gets
dispatched to apprehend Marquee
following in the [__] ass way of every
Zen and male this Captain nobuwagi Zenon
tells his men that she must have killed
Ogie in his sleep or in the bathroom
obviously it's severely under estimating
her stream this kukuru unit is made up
of Xena men who do not manifest enemy
technique but are still able to use
cursed energy they end up fighting Maki
in the cursed Spirit Room and Surround
her with at least 20 men from the unit
standing there alone looking like the
complete hellhound where the dragon bone
in one hand and Mai's Creation in the
other Marquee can only think about her
sister she wonders what her plan was and
if she should really have given up on
becoming a sorcerer alongside my she
figures that that might have been the
right answer all along and apologizes to
her sister for potting her through all
of the pain that she did from around her
the 20 kukuru unit Fighters all attack
or Mahi remembers Mai's final request
destroy everything Mikey opens her eyes
just as one of the men attempts to slash
her instantly and on some freaking
Matrix level [__] she avoids the blade
and cuts off both of the man's hands in
one fluid motion then vaults over his
back and cuts down several of his allies
before 5 finally be hitting the fodder
fall below her despite their numbers the
kukuru units frankly nothing compared to
the now unrestricted Marty who
effortlessly kills one after another and
successively brutal fashion oh my Lord I
love this fight like the look on
everyone's freaking face as she's just
annihilating them as perfect this
absolute egg novawaki arrives back
somehow expecting Maki to actually have
been finished off already yet as he
stroll certain he's unpleasantly
surprised to see that all of his men
have been turned into bloody corpses by
an unscathed Marquee suddenly our new
beloved icon of female strength notice
as a surge of cursed energy nearby
coming from chojiro zinin instantly
she's tossed flying up into the ear by a
pair of gigantic stone hands the then
attempt to smash her while she's falling
back down to earth nobody recognizes
this attack as chojodo's curse technique
and note that the hey have now arrived
which by the way is a group made up of
only the strongest comprised of everyone
in the family with a semi grade 1 or
higher ranking so now the proper fight
begins this stone hands aren't enough to
hold Marky as she tears her way back out
novawaki and chojiro attempt to stop her
but she jams her hands into their throat
at blinding speed literally killing them
both before they could even react Ryan
to watching this loses his paralyzing
technique to try and hold Maki in place
while yelling for janichi to hurry up
and finish her off while jinichi Sprints
in to kill her Maki fights back and
forcibly breaks out of ranta's technique
this literally sends his technique back
at him or something similar to that
inflicting a horrendous amount of damage
to his face still despite bleeding
profusely Ryan to make sure to tell
junichi that Maki has indeed become just
like toji however unlike toji who never
decided to destroy the entire clan on a
whim Mahi will do that if she is not
killed here and now junichi attacks
Marky and launches a huge number of
cursed energy propelled fists running
down from the sky at her this pummels
everything and the immediate area which
causes ranta to believe they actually
succeeded at his final moments rancid
then collapses on his knees while they
smile thinking they won and succumbs to
the previous strain of his injuries
while Maki the complete and utter God
walks out of the dust and smoke with
janichi's head hanging from her fist
finally the misogynistic neoyazinen who
secondly under being an absolute hoe as
the head of the hay Squad confronts
Marky via a small traditional
japanese-style bridge that extends over
a nice Pond standing there he of all
people calls Marky crawl and asks if she
even has a human heart to which Marky
will they cold and callous face replies
no as your heart has already been taken
from her skipping into a flashback join
aoya's childhood we find that he's
always been wrapped in Cotton wool and
constantly praised by his family members
he was recognized as a genius and many
always believed he would grow into the
head of the clan after naobito love how
Mega me just showed up on the block out
of nowhere and messed up that entire
plan for him anyways anyways now you
heard of a black sheep any Clan who
didn't have any cursed energy and went
to see how pitiful that person was
however after seeing him Naomi was
physically shaken upon seeing toji's
Cold Yet unconsumed eyes back in reality
now nalia initiates the fight quickly
sending a series of Rapid punches
towards her however Marky is able to
Parry the majority of them or try and
account the number of movements in that
singular moment sadly while she's big
braining his technique now he interrupts
it and grabs her causing her to be
frozen in Sonic frame then using the
Extreme Velocity his technique provides
naioya kicks Maki through several stone
structures surrounding the area now
you're standing there thinking he is the
top G as adamant to himself that Marquis
is not toji regardless of a new Boost in
power yes she ain't even at the same
power level yet bro she just unlocked
the full extent of her Heavenly
restriction like Goku wasn't all of a
sudden Super Saiyan 3 when he unlocked
Super Saiyan 1 like it's not how it
works you've got you've still gotta
train and build time you know anyways
now you thinks that the sin of
insignificant people is the ignorance of
strength everyone misjudged toji because
of his lack of cursed energy and naillou
doesn't believe anyone other than Gojo
truly understood who he actually was
using his curse technique now he
continually builds up momentum and
overwhelms Marky with one high speed
move after another being a mess of toji
in goju Fanboy now he desires to prove
that he is the only one who will stand
with him as one of the strongest not
Marquee even with her improved abilities
Marky is starting to get hurt by narious
attacks and struggles to keep up
admitting that this situation is getting
bad for neoya and like in his fight with
choso he won't stop building up speed
this time he understands that strength
equals weight and speed and plans to
pierce Marty at Max velocity having
already gone supersonic Mikey gained a
steel body that is broken away from
cursed energy in exchange for Maya's
life she welcomes a head-on collision
and takes the stance of the shiranui
Garter which for all of my Japanese
lovers out there is a specific form that
sumo wrestlers take Marquis attempts to
take on the brunt of now your supersonic
speed in order to stop his movements
even if it means sacrificing ropes
appearing to stay through maki's
defensive strategy now he attacks her
with his palm in doing so it forces Maki
to follow the 24 frames per second roll
of projection sorcery failure to do so
means being frozen inside a frame for
one second like what just happened with
her previously when she was kicked
across the yard still moving at top
speed and seeing his adversary as
nothing more than an imposter Neo
believes Maki is frozen and prepares to
finish her off however Maki actually
isn't even phased by his technique and
is even obeying the specific 24-frame
rule of it now being able to move fast
enough Mikey turns around and counter
attacks and accepting the area's path
with her first now your attempts to call
Monkey a fake but before he finishes she
smashes his face into the ground with a
monstrous punch that ends the fight and
he forms now your skull now acting like
the absolute boss she is she looks down
on her pathetic bloody cousin and asks
him to repeat that
so I guess all of the action in regards
to the Xenon Clan mutilation ends there
but we still have just one more massive
moments I probably should Chuck in here
for all of you guys because I oh my Lord
it wraps everything up just perfectly
having Lefty Battlefield now Marky finds
her mother in a kitchen area like of
course like where else would she be and
he's dead in the household it's just so
so freaking sex to stop them marky's
mother tells you to stay back but Maki
wants to know why she screamed at her to
come back earlier in the corridor to
destroy to even recall what happened
only moments prior mucky's mother can
only ask what Maki is talking about
dissatisfied Marquee approaches her
mother who yells out in panic several
times before a blood is splattered on
the wall okay I'm not gonna lie this
does confuse me a slight bird I think
Mumsy twin the blade on herself right
here but honestly let me know what you
guys think down below I really don't
think Marky actually sliced up her mum
outside throughout and around the estate
the hay and the kokoru squads have been
completely decimated with their corpses
lining the area somehow like the
cockroach she is nailya heavily injured
but still somehow barely alive walks
around pouring blood from his face until
he finally collapses through a door onto
the ground inside he mocks Marky for not
ending him and leaving him like this
when out of freaking nowhere marky's
mother walks up behind him with her
throat already slits and bleeding so
she's definitely approaching death for
sure but still somehow holding the
kitchen knife difficult is in an estate
like thing nail you who's currently too
pitiful to even protect himself then
there's probably the woman he hated the
most the mother of Marky and Mai stab
him through the back with a goddamn
kitchen knife which by the way is
something that this [__] said should
happen to any female who is weaker than
any man so like oh my God you've got to
chill out with him sneaky little like
four Shadow Wings here and there now it
calls her a piece of trash by either way
ends up dying a pitiful death with a
woman laying on top of him unable to do
anything about it on top and fading away
the girl's mother admits that she really
was was glad to have given birth to two
amazing girls
after absolutely ruining the entire
student family tree Mahi exits the
property with Maya's body Mama arrives
just moments later having been chasing
behind Maya and concern seeing now that
Mai has died as a result of not being
there to help Momo cries and sobs over
her regrets silently Mikey hands over
Mai's body to which Momo asks Marquee
what she's going to do now but our girl
still obviously shaken remains
completely silent as she walks away with
a blade in her hand later on it is
explained that these inning clan members
who were not even prison at the estate
that day also died violent deaths Mucky
literally hunted them all down in one
day and killed them all it's crazy no
residuals were found other than Trace
Amounts from a cursed tool skipping back
now to the moments before leaving tingen
yujin migami were given the third and
final third Year's location that being
the gambling madman Hikari Kenji it is
explained that Hikari is currently just
chilling out while being suspended and
makes money as a bookie for an
underground fighting Club the spread pit
level Fight Club puts Sorcerers against
one another in hand-to-hand combats
these Spectators are mostly
non-sorcerers which just goes to show
that hakari literally doesn't care about
the Jutsu regulations now arriving at a
parking garage the two Sorcerers removed
the Jujutsu uniforms in an attempt to
try and trick Hikari into thinking they
aren't associated with the school Mega
me goes on to say that he may not
associate with him if he realizes
they're also students from jujutsutic
it's a great area for them but to Hikari
they might as well be with the
higher-ups if he finds out who they
truly are Yuji wonders though if akari
will actually help twitch Mega me is
unsure regardless of the situation
though they need his strength for the
culling game and will do their best to
recruit him mikimi and Yuji walk into
the entrance of the parking garage in a
myth by two men the security guard look
and do tells the kids to get lost and
instantly throws a strong hook at Mega
me however it stops just short right
before hitting his face as the security
guard slowly who's back his first he
tells Mega me that the one rule of the
fight Club is that nobody is supposed to
say anything about the club he demands
to know who told them and threatens to
beat him up after finding out I honestly
love this whole idea with like Hikari
being like a Brad Pitt type character
having this fight club and everything it
makes me feel like gigay is a part of
the generation that I grew up as a part
of and watch these movies while I was
growing up and just really enjoy them
and everything and now we're getting to
see you know like his little enjoyments
from Western culture plopped right into
his story here which is absolutely
fantastic Mega me claims not to have
gotten the person's name before he
killed them himself it was a cocky
sorcerer that disappeared about a month
ago to which the guy recalls some dude
who disappeared about a month ago but is
unable to verify who it was exactly
mikumi asks to take his place instead
and threatens to murf The Bodyguard if
he refuses the manager then gives him
message from the boss to add an
additional fighter to today's tournament
however only on the condition that Yuji
is selected as the fighter knowing that
Yuji is perfect for the job making me
keeps up his act and asks that he fight
instead that it explains to make me
though that the boss doesn't like him
and refuses to let some fights to watch
migami having noticed all of the cameras
around him decides to happily accept the
invitation dude is out playing like some
4D level chest trying to trick everyone
including Yuji at the moment like yuji's
probably just standing there utterly
confused after leaving and confirming
that akari must have been observing them
through the cameras they go over the
plan firstly your tears to look for and
make contact with a carry on the inside
while Megami attempts to sneak in the
parking garage from outside obviously
this is hella risky because if they
discover Mega me sneaking around they
will probably instantly distrust
ug so if they are discovered they decide
to use Force to make their way through
to Hikari but only as a final Resort
even though the best course of action
would be to let Yuji do his thing first
tsukumi's deadline is fast approaching
which causes megamek to get a bit
recluse it's currently 5 PM on the 10th
of November leaving the group nine days
to rescue sakumi before the deadline
closes that evening Yuji returns to the
parking garage for the fight the man
there preps Yuji by explaining the
details of how the tournament works
there are only two rules no retreating
and no Jujutsu which obviously piguji is
completely fine with as the dude was
first and foremost a physical Beast
anyways anyways now heading down the
stairs towards the arena Yuji asks the
dude what the boss is like to what she
says to Yuji that he can only find out
if he actually meets him he then
explains that there are two types of
matches scripted and unscripted ones
these so-called scripted matches are
actually script written by the boss and
the Fuji is able to put on a show in an
unscripted fight it will likely get his
attention possibly resulting in some
kind of Mace hanging arriving at the
arena now which is like this dopa
section of the garage where the Upper
Floor has been almost entirely renovated
into an area that allows Spectators to
view from above Yuji is introduced to
his opponent and someone that I can 100
say surprise is absolutely like everyone
here even rereading the section I forgot
this Beast made his appearance here with
that good old fighter announce a voice
the infamous John Bobby Begins the
tournament by introducing the newcomer
itadori against no one other than Panda
and in monitoring room somewhere nearby
chilling like the absolute King he is
Hikari says with his associate as the
fight begins he expresses his
displeasure as he believes things are
starting to cool off Hikari doesn't
believe there is any fun in knowing
who's going to win an unscripted fight
he doesn't think anyone will be able to
defeat Panda and is barely watching
however the lovely lady with him points
his attention over to the television we
Eugene is absolutely pummeling panda in
spectacular fashion by the way for those
wondering like the comet says just above
I'm pretty sure Hikari and Panda
obviously know each other and are
probably extremely well on that like
classmate level type beat or friendship
back in the fight Eugene panda work
together to put on a show that
entertains everyone watching in fact the
fight is so damn good it impresses even
the goat himself John freak and Bobby
who screams that this is the best fight
he's ever seen while the two trade blows
Eugene Panda have a cheeky conversation
to exchange info Panda has been allowed
into the fight club but akari and the
other cute third year with him are
actively avoiding Panda as well after
finishing their small conversation and
agreeing to end the fights Yuki lands a
powerful fake body shot that Panda sells
with a way over the top reaction to
convince everyone that he's being
defeated big Bobby announces Yuji as the
winner leaving a lasting impression on
everyone watching even akari upstairs
and has little content box admits that
he's impressed with yuji's ability to
fight in three dimensions while still
dazzling the spectacles he calls one of
his managers and gets him to bring Yuji
up to his office he wants to strike a
deal with him while the iron is hot and
right scrubs for yuji's future fights
this chick chilly nearby who turns out
to be be another of Jiu Jitsu High's
third years called Carrara Hoshi tells
akari that it all just sounds boring to
her elsewhere at the same time Mega me
like the slimo for years uses a deuce
Shadow to eavesdrop on the conversation
without being seen he manually phone
asks Sakari what to do about the other
brat referring to Meek me who's like
right behind him to what shikari says he
plans to have Carrara keep an eye on him
after leaving the area Panda finds
Megami in a nearby Forest he asks Megami
if he thinks that Yuji will be able to
contact takari to which Mega me thinks
that he will but asks Panda why he
actually hasn't seen Hikari himself
Panda knows where Hikari is and says
that he's in the monitoring room on the
roof but can't get close to the door
because of the Hoshi girls curse
technique it doesn't matter what he
seems to do walk or run he cannot
approach the door Mickey asks if it's
only active when Carrara is in the
monitoring room but panda is unsure
since she's always with akari rather
than forcing the issue panda affected
Spectators to avoid getting on akari's
bad side he goes on to say that he
thinks yuji's charm will work on akari
but is also apprehensive because Yuji is
an extremely bad liar as we all know
from literally every time this dude has
had to lie about like anything so in an
attempt to save his ass Panda gave him
some tips beforehand just in case
something random happens worst case
scenario would be for Hikari to discover
Yuji as which is you too high and boost
him out Panda wants to secure the area
and monitor the door to prevent this
meaning that they'll need to murk a few
of the fodder security guards to get up
there he knows where all the cameras are
and their blind spots as well as their
positions of all of their lockouts Mega
me acknowledges that they might have a
solid plan but carrara's technique
remains a random factor in everything
that they do so if akari and Carrara do
end up getting Yuji outside the door
Mickey says that they'll just have to
give up on their objective altogether
later on and after winning another match
in the fight club Yuki sin's Mega me a
text at 12 58 saying that his meeting
with akari at 1pm while each of the five
Lookouts maintain their positions
Carrara nicknames him you and shares
that Hikari had to repeat a year in
junior high Judy notes how cheerful
Carrara is to which she replies it's
because akari is starting to feel hot
again having received the text making me
snakes into the first guard's Shadow and
mounts him from behind he chokes the man
unconscious tapes his mouth and zip ties
his hands together all done extremely
quickly the second guard then walks in
without noticing a single thing as
immerse Megami quickly slides into his
shadow then continuing on the UFC style
takedowns he knocks him out with a
perfect triangle choke at the same time
two other gods notice Panda playing with
a tire initially confused one of them
wonders if he eats fish sausage while
the other recognizes Panda from the
tournament suddenly Panda switches on
them and knocks them both out before
taking the sausage then hitting up the
emergency stairs panda regroups with
migami on the roof and moves with him to
guard the monitoring room door when
suddenly and unexpectedly Ferrara walks
out of the room just below them for a
moment Mega me and Panda just stand
there completely stunned looking up
Carrara quickly notices the pier and
instantly makes a connection that Mega
me and you are both from Jujutsu high
like Panda Carrara believing that
herkari is in danger reaches through her
phone and tries to contact him however
mikami summons his base of the shikigami
the Divine dog totality to try and stop
her the shikigami rushes Carrara and
tries to restrain her but it sent flying
back into Mega me having dropped her
phone Carrara runs towards a monitoring
room while Panda who's kind of just
standing there tries to explain that
they're not enemies Carrara doesn't
believe that they have a simple request
for Hikari and is upset with him for
simply betraying them due to carrara's
technique holding Panda back Mega me
orders has a Divine dog to intercept her
path this instantly stops her but migami
is also suddenly pulled towards the
shikagami he realizes that in addition
to being unable to reach Carrara he is
now unable to even separate from his
Divine dog while he thinks about how
this first technique Works neither he
nor Panda have noticed a small random
star symbol on Panda's ass that reads
star am I like all my Lord bring back
Professor diavolo from the one punch man
video we've got some space facts here
boys so Amai is actually a star in the
Milky Way and Maya is also like the
traditional name of the star known as
Delta cruxes it is visible from Earth
and is only 364 light years away or if
you want that in miles it's about 2.139
quadrillion miles away anyways meanwhile
inside of the monitoring room Hikari the
final special grade student finally
meets with Yuji for the first time and
typical Jujutsu cars in fashion akari
had some other bizarre but intriguing
question he asks Yuji would you believe
me if I said you could work for one hour
a day and make 1 million yen a month
unsure as anyone would be in the
situation Yuji just blankly stays back
in confusion confused Yuki asks what he
would need to do but akari says he would
have to pay 200 000 Yen obviously like a
cheeky Guru scam right here but you know
what I like a lot more than
materialistic things knowledge the more
you learn the more you earn you know I
read a book a day not to show off it's
again about knowledge in fact something
happened that changed my life I bumped
into a mentor like yeah okay dude
totally I'm sure that's how it actually
works even Yuji out of everyone doesn't
agree as he thinks that this one just
feels kind of shady Hikari agrees and
points out that it's a classic con with
get rich quick scammers sell turps it's
an obvious scam but akari notes that
there are still a lot of people who will
fall for it and adds it up to something
that he calls the fever Hikari explains
they're both the scammer and the scammed
are in a favor to change their lives
people get high on the fever and make
stupid decisions yet without it people
can never fall in love akari loves the
fever and asks Yuji if he knows the most
direct way of engaging with it dude
Curry is such a such a tricky character
to get around and like write and stuff
Yuji kisses correctly and says that it's
gambling I find this like part
absolutely hilarious but apparently lots
of girls dumped a curry in the past due
to his constant gambling but guys want
to points out that life itself is
actually a gamble Society tramples on
losers who don't know when to quit but
akari points out that everyone gambles
what people truly hate is losing a
character goes on to say that he wants
to control the fever of the entire
country using his fight club which is
really like the Fight Club movie if you
think about it like hikari's character
in general is rarely playing on that
Brad Pitt side of uh the main
character's brain and everything he's
going for that like I want to change the
entire world Prospect or like the entire
world feeling he says that he wants to
take advantage of the current chaos and
expand his business making the Jujutsu
headquarters aware of his Ambitions
needing strong allies for this he asks
Yuji if he wants to get high on his
fever Yuji prepares to ask for help when
all of a sudden they're interrupted by a
phone call which completely changes the
atmosphere after it ends he offers Yuji
a drink which he refuses because of his
age hearing this he brings up out of the
blue that started Gojo can't drink
either Juju pretends not to know who
Gojo is but akari who finds a suspicious
finishes his drink and asks if Yuji is a
spy from Juju to take before Yuji can
speak up to Defenders case akari tosses
the drink glass right at his face Yugi
deflects the cup but akari quickly
activates his curse technique summoning
two tall sliding doors that attempt to
close YouTube between them Yuji jumps
above the horizontal doors and tries to
speak up but akari continues his attack
trapping him with his doors and kicking
him in the face while revealing that a
call from Carrara means something bad
has happened Yoji recalls what megumi
said about only asking for cooperation
and hit but zakari in an attempt to get
him to listen however the third year
doesn't give up and refuses because now
his fever is running cold meanwhile
outside the room Carrara is in a
deadlock with panda and mega me since
they are stuck making me tries to
explain that they're not on the Jujutsu
high side side and they need hikari's
help but Carrara just doesn't listen
confused as to what happened between
them and the higher-ups panda explains
to mikami that conservative members of
the community prefer traditional Jujutsu
while akari has Blended hers for
technology so just think of the moment
during the shipuya incident where mimiko
and nanako got absolutely murked by
sukuna and he was like oh a curse camera
technique cool that was a blended
technique as it had been like blended
with the camera and the cell phone
Carrara points out they're just you too
high lost because they have their
priorities backwards but adds that they
always have Gojo to clean up their
messes so why are they even here asking
for help me give me reveals to her that
satello Gojo was sealed during shabuya
but Carrara makes a face of comic
disbelief as she obviously just can't
believe that that could ever happen
realizing this Megami decides to
activate his rabbit Escape summoning
dozens of his rabbit shikigami as a
large swarm of rabbit shikigami cover
the roof he notices that each of the
rabbits are marked with a symbol saying
a Crux none of the robots can actually
get near the monitor room where migami
notices another symbol starget Crux has
been placed the rabbits quickly spread
across the entire roof so that migami
can see where and where they can't go
seeing this Carrero repels them but is
still confused at the whole point of it
carrara's innate technique Mark
shukigami the same as Sorcerers so just
like with the Divine dog Carrara
believes that Mega me will attract all
of the rabbits and suffocate inside of
them however he suddenly dispels them
all Megami asks Panda however Escape was
to which Panda confirms that the
shukigami were attracted to him and the
second floor but they couldn't reach
Carrara or the monitor room to war pen
finally figures out that he has been
marked with his symbol Amai and mega me
has been marked with a Crux Megami isn't
sure what's going on but he knows that
carrara's curse technique is very likely
based on the constellation of stars Rara
notices that Mega me is figuring out how
her technique works and puts her
attention on her Mega me turns to
Carrara and says that it might be based
on the Southern Cross constellation
Carrara is surprised that he gets
correctly but gives it away that he got
it correct with a reaction which
continues to add to her frustration
Chrono said if migami continues to
figure out how the technique works then
it'll eventually reach the monitor room
Kara resolves to hold him off and try to
prevent that no matter what Megami
thanks tsukumi for teaching him about
the Southern Cross but is still confused
because he knows it should have four
specific points Mega Million Panda get
close to one another and discuss
carrara's curse technique he initially
thought that it assigned them each a
point on the Southern Cross to maintain
distance between each point however this
can't be the case because Carrara can
approach the door and mega me can
approach Panda making me realizes that
it's more likely that the acoustic Nick
has a determined route where there is a
sequential order for who can go near
what depending on what point they've
been marked worth Panda considers that
the technique doesn't affect the yozer
the mega me debunks this because the
Divine dog totality couldn't approach
Carrara earlier of Carrara and the door
both hit stars that repel Megami and
Panda then Carrara could simply flee
Mickey being Panda surmised that this
must mean the Southern Cross has five or
more points as if there were only four
stars one of them should be able to
approach the enemy sorcerer since that
isn't the case here there must be a
first star between them that they must
go through in order to reach her and the
door Panda asks what they should do if
there are six or seven points but migami
says five is already too many to make
sense for a cross obviously though if
you live in like NZ or Australia or even
pretty much anywhere in the southern
hemisphere you know for a fact that
there are actually indeed five stars in
the Southern Cross anyway anyway knowing
that she might be foiled soon Carrara
goes on the offensive she ferociously
jumps on the hood of the car and marks
it with himai sending it flying up at
Panda the car flips into Panda but he
manages to catch it and assures Mega me
that he's okay one megaby runs away
Panda tosses the car away from him to
what's making me concerned reminds Panda
not to throw the car away or else the
Mark will simply Attract it back to him
and as he says this the car comes
shooting right back at Panda slamming to
rexley into his head while sprinting
they give me surmises that contact needs
to be made by the user to place a star
Carrara marked migami by marking his
curse energy through his Divine dog in
order to Mark more objects like the
monitor room door or the car they need
to be charged beforehand while someone
else's cursed to energy honestly Mega
Meat is just so freaking big brain right
now have he had the raw strength of
Eugene dude would actually like be pure
Insanity anyways anyways Mega me focuses
on seeing the curse energy residuals on
the car and find some from someone other
than Carrara continuing with his theory
Mega me assumes the technique doesn't
have a long range and eventually finds a
parking stop marked with a fifth star
Mimosa Mega me quickly touches the
parking stop and doesn't notice any more
residuals he knows carrara's curse
energy is already marked with a star so
he assumes they can't use the curse
technique to Mark another object with a
Crux and attract more objects to him
however to me give me shock a bunch of
objects marked with the Crux are already
heading directly for him finally it is
explained that carrara's curse technique
love Rendezvous marks five stars with a
Southern Cross motive to Target curse
energy for one star to approach another
it must follow a determined order or
else one of the targets for the same
star will attract dirt the order follows
the stars from nearest furthest on a
diagram constellations come across as
flat but space is actually a
three-dimensional area and each star is
a different distance from Earth migami
was marked with a Crux so you must
travel through mimosa and Ganan in order
to reach the Crux or in my monkey brain
speak he has to go through the parking
stop Mark then Carrara and finally he
can make it to the monitoring door
anyways anyways cryo admits she's
impressed that migami figured out how
her technique works that being said
prayer believes Megami was too quick to
conclude that more objects couldn't be
thrown at him while Carrara can't Mark
more than one star with the same icon
she can simply remove the monitor room
door marker and Mark other things with
migami's motoff instead suddenly Harare
is called off guard when the Divine dog
randomly reappears behind her megamese
jacked up shikigami quickly immobilizes
Carrara confusing her until she comes to
the realization that Mega me never
dispelled it instead he was able to
guess which one would attract the other
and maneuver so there was a wall between
them then after waiting for a while he
unjammed the Divine dog from the wall so
he could take advantage of the fact that
Carrara was now approachable with
Carrara now stuck it forces her to
release the love Rendezvous making me
quickly restrains Carrara so that she
doesn't run away but simply asks her to
listen to what he has to say he then
dispels his Divine dog totality or
simply asking her to listen still
skeptical crowd doesn't think Miami
could have known whether he or the
shukigami would have been pulled Mega me
and met said he took a gamble but now he
knows that the one with the higher curse
energy output does the attracting
initially the Divine dog pulled Mega me
but the opposite occurred when Mega me
reinforced his body with cursed energy
we can be the inlets Carrera go and begs
her to listen because he's frankly just
no time confuses to why he would release
her Carrara decides to believe him
however the monitor room door has
suddenly seen flying off its hinges with
Yuji bursting out migami quickly
realizes that Yuji has been head outside
the room and right on cue the fighting
theme Hikari walks outside visibly
irritated with the whole situation Fuji
tells Mega me and Panda to stay out of
it prompting her character believe that
he's being underestimated he immediately
throws a devastating punch that smashes
yuji's face and sends him flipping
across the roof Hikari eventually
notices that Yuji isn't even resisting
and in that moment the first year
Springs back to his feet standing there
Yuji spurts blood out of his nose while
akari is just blown away no team that
his adversary doesn't even intend to
dodge to him yuji's lack of resistance
all but confirms he's not a spy so akari
says they'll hear Yuji out on the
condition that he can remain standing
and flew is up as curse energy Carrara
urges him to listen but akari claims
that he just said he would before asking
Yuji why he's asking him for help
specifically Yuji says that all of his
seniors have confirmed Hikari as strong
annoying him akari punches Yuji again
and while he's railing through the air
usually compares to Carry's reinforced
punches to getting hurt with a serrated
bat which like oh my Lord the cheese
grater level of curse energy right here
irritated Curry yells at Yuji stating
that Sorcerers understand asking one
another for a favor is equal to asking
someone to put their life on the line in
order for her character takes such a
risk he needs Yuji to prove here and now
that he has the fever to convince some
Yuji claims that he doesn't have a fever
and is just a cog a cognitive machine
that Sorcerers need to eliminate curse
Spirits typical depresso Yuji right here
like even akari finds his answer
extremely boring so he decides to wind
up another punch prompting mikami to
express his concern akari strikes Yuji
with the hardest blow yet
line across the roof into a wall and
appearing to finally knock him out
Hikari begins to tell them to leave but
Yuji suddenly reappears behind him
Hikari is genuinely surprised and backs
up wondering how he's still standing
after suffering three literally
mind-altering blows he asks Yuji what he
is to what she replies while the same
answer is before he believes His
function is getting rid of curses and
since Kari isn't necessary for that Yuji
decides he won't stop until he agrees
Yuji think it's Up All In A Curry's face
and asks him what his function is Hikari
who still surprised asks himself if this
is the look of a cog in fever he goes to
punch Yuji once again but finally
Carrara interrupts and manages to get
hikari's attention she asks Sakari a
Fuji's fever is burning hot enough for
him yet standing near he recognizes that
carrara's point is undeniable
acknowledging that it is indeed true he
then suddenly agrees to hear Yuji out
and tells me give me and Panda the that
he's willing to cut a deal honestly if
you're confused as to what happened
don't worry because Mickey and Panda are
like just as confused as everyone else
as to what's just happened he asks
Carrara if what they said convinced them
to watch she confirms skipping forward
akari finally sits down and listens to
what they've got to say he's completely
surprised to hear that Gojo was sealed
and Panda adds that masamichi also died
and they fight with kakuganji recently
after Shibuya obviously this is like the
first that they've all heard of Jagger's
death as well Eugene mikami a concern
for panda santiaga was pretty much his
dad Hikari expresses that he's bummed
out now that everyone who's ever taken
care of him is out of the picture
honestly I think like as in everyone he
was probably referring to Yaga Gojo
nanami and like maybe even ghetto from
the school as well before he passed away
Hikari agrees to help combat the culling
game however he tells him to not get the
wrong idea and makes it a point that
everyone understands that this is a deal
and that they must return the favor at
some point in the future and want to
know more and asks what exactly he
desires but making me Cuts in and
comments that he doesn't think whatever
it is will be difficult which annoys
akari Hikari calls Megami a sea urchin
head or a [__] pretty much and asks
him what he could possibly know probably
mega mega flicks on him saying that he's
literally the head of his hidden Clan
who starts off and is like no I don't
want the role Marquee like maybe you
should have her and now he's flexing on
Hikari right here shocked Hikari finds
us even more of a surprise than the news
about Gojo and Yaga he believes that
with the backing of The Big Three
Families making revisions to society
will be easy however the funny part
about this is that like I just talked
about earlier in the video Mahi actually
destroys the entire sitting Clan the
next day so her fight and all of that
with Maya dying Etc happens after this
point so I don't know why Giga decided
to write this backwards here maybe he
just thought of it afterwards and
thought he'd throw that in just to add a
bit more like confusion of the story so
thank you very much Keke with everyone
in agreement Yuji states that they need
to decide what colony to go to when
suddenly cocaine remember like the game
interface thingy that was explained
right at the beginning of the arc
appears above Yuji and makes a loud
ringing noise cocaine announces that one
player has added a new rule to the game
allowing players to have access to
information on other players this
information includes their name number
of points number of rules added and
their current Colony this rule was added
by a new mysterious looking dude named
Hajime kashimo a sorcerer who's over 400
years old no sakuna and is currently
dominating the entirety of Tokyo's
number two Colony after making the
announcement kogane introduces itself to
Yuji its voice differs to that of the
announcements because now it's acting as
liaison for the Cullen game assigned to
Yuji instead of the announcers Megami
doesn't understand why Yuji has already
been considered as a player before
entering a colony which is actually
super interesting and I'd love to like
know what you guys think it could be but
like Yuji I believe it has something to
do with sukona and most likely the fact
that sakuna was a cursed object linked
to kinjaku in some kind of way Megami
points out that that's still strange
because Yuji and Jester sukuna's fingers
of his own will unlike the past
Sorcerers who were in contracts with
kinjaku so yeah there definitely is
something else going on what if perhaps
it was actually the valve sakuna made
with Yuji you know the one that he
doesn't actually remember currently even
happened just an idea Yuji hisco game
show him his own player info amigami
uses the list to fight kashimo
identifying them as the one who added
the rule Megami believes that they can
get through the culling game without
killing anyone by forcing someone with
enough points to add another role the
two players that already fit their bill
are G makashimo and heromi hikaruma in
order to save sakumi the first rule they
have to add will need to offset rule
eight Megami states that they can do so
by adding a rule that allows players to
transfer points between each other after
aiding that rule Megami suggests adding
another one that allows players to spin
points to remove themselves from the
game entirely to which Hikari points out
that that might actually conflict with
the long lasting rules of the game but
Mega me figures that maybe it'll work
under the right conditions but
ultimately it's up to the game master
and regardless the team now has a plan
while they look for the sorcerer known
as Angel they will also search for
Hajime and hegaruma then attempt to take
them down for their points
so that officially brings us to the very
end of what is Juju Kaiser's perfect
preparation Arc and obviously this Arc
in general is absolutely massive in
terms of just the information that gets
given to us in regards to the culling
game which is going to be going on in
the next Arc finally so we are actually
going to be getting into that along with
like all of the fights there and you
know like just marky's Massacre and like
who destroying her entire clan in
general leaving only her and migami as a
part of the zening clan or like I guess
Xenon and fushiguro clans lift you know
that's all that's left over from the
clan and technically Mega me is the head
of a headless Clan like I said right at
the end of the video there with you know
Hikari and you know like finally we were
actually introduced to Hikari here which
is an absolutely dope character I never
expected him to be such an interesting
character and most likely based off like
a brad pitt-esque type character from
you know like their entire fight club
scene especially with his entire Fight
Club and wanting to change you know like
the Jiu Jitsu of society it felt that
way to me at least anyway obviously if
you guys have enjoyed this video and
want to see more stuff just like it in
the future then make sure you hit the
Subscribe button and also so be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with pushing my stuff to a
bunch of new amazing people and of
course we are like almost at 100K Subs
we're only 9k away now which is like
freaking amazing so if you do watch all
my videos and stuff then do make sure to
hit that subscribe button and smash the
you know like the Bell alert so that you
do get all my videos when they first you
know releasing everything but anyway for
now it's been your professional
degenerate dear Volo and I will see you
all in a bit bye